[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700,000 words the Bible can generate a
lot of questions if you'd like answers
to your Bible questions you've come to
the right place now here's your host
Pastor Doug bachelor president and
speaker of amazing
facts Hello friends would you like to
hear an amazing fact when it comes to
Human Rights and religious freedom North
Korea is one of the most oppressive
Nations a place where Christians are
routinely imprisoned or even killed for
their faith but the Believers just
across the border in South Korea have
not let the cruel government stop them
from sharing the gospel with their
brothers in the north depending on wind
conditions every week since 1991 a group
of South Korean Christian Commandos
gather at the border of North Korea to
release hundreds of balloons in this
program called operation dandelion the
red helium filled balloons printed with
the entire Gospel of Mark are carried by
the breeze High over the heavily guarded
communist border after years of
experience they've learned they can even
poke varying numbers of small pinholes
in the balloons to help control how far
they will float before they land it's
been reported thousands have come to
Christ through reading these segments of
scriptures scattered across the
communist country via balloon perhaps
this is why Jesus compares the words of
scripture to seeds stay with us friends
we're going to learn more as amazing
facts brings you this edition of Bible
answers
[Music]
live you're listening to Bible answers
live honest answers to your Bible
questions our phone lines are now open
if you have a Bible related question
call us at 1 1800 God says that's 1 1800
7297 let's get to our first bible
question with Pastor Doug
Bachelor we'll be heading to the phones
here in just a moment want to let you
know we do have phone lines open and
that number if you want to call in with
your Bible question 800 God says 8004
63729 7 Welcome Friends to another
edition of Bible answers live my name is
Doug Bachelor and Pastor Jean Ross is
coming back from a speaking appointment
in Maryland and he'll be back in his
saddle this next week but before we go
to our phones for tonight in the Bible
questions let's pray together Father in
heaven we just want to thank you for
your blessings we thank you Lord for the
opportunity and even this medium of
studying the Bible and sharing the word
with friends and uh brothers and sisters
in the Lord around the country and the
world bless BL this broad cast Lord to
your glory and to the honor of your name
and we pray in that name of your son
Jesus
amen well friends I was uh interested to
read the amazing fact about the
Christians in Korea South Korea that are
looking for ways to share the gospel and
not only do they send balloons where the
gospel of Mark the entire Gospel of Mark
is printed in Korean on the outside of
the balloon and they're easy to spot
these balloons I think they release them
at night
Karen and I a few years ago were at the
border the demilitarized zone there
where you've got no man's land between
the North and the South and they were
just looking for a way to get the gospel
into that country where it's forbidden
not only do they have balloons that
carry the gospel printed on the balloon
but every now and then they'll have
these extra large balloons they'll
release at night that will carry actual
Bibles or Bible tracks across the border
and it's very dangerous because when
some of these North Korean people uh get
these things and read them they can be
in a lot of trouble if they're found
with this material but what do you do
Jesus said unless they have eternal
life they don't uh if they don't know
the gospel they can't live forever and
you need to take some risk Jesus said
that when you share the word it's like
scattering seed and it will certainly
bear a crop he promises in Isaiah that
his word will not return void but it
will bring forth the purpose for which
he has sent it and you can read the
parable in Matthew 13:3 where Jesus
compares the word of God to seeds being
sown that word will always bring a
Revival in somebody's life and uh Jesus
said the words I speak they are spirit
and they are life if you'd like to know
about how to experience that Revival we
have a book special book I wrote It's
called 12 steps to Revival you read
through this and you'll know what do I
do to find that first love again how can
the word of God bring that new life into
my heart all you have to do is call and
we will send you 12 steps to Revival
it's free the number 800 835
6747 again call 800 835 6747 to get your
free copy of 12 steps to Revival and if
you have a Bible question
8463 7297 brings you to our studio with
that we're going to go to our first
caller for tonight and we're talking to
in Columbus Ohio welcome Juan you're on
the
air hi Pastor how you doing good thank
you for calling
in all right um I have a question about
Leviticus
1714 um recently I donated blood and
someone from my church said that that
was bad and this is the verse that they
use to tell me that I shouldn't donate
blood all right let me read that yeah
I'll read that for our friends that are
listening it says Leviticus
17:14 for it is the life of All Flesh
the blood of it for the life thereof I
said unto the children of Israel you
shall eat the blood of no manner of
Beast or flesh for the life of All Flesh
is in the blood thereof whoever eats it
shall be cut off well this is a command
that goes back not only here in
Leviticus God said the same thing to
Noah if you read that in Genesis oh I
think it's chapter nine and you even
find it in the book of Acts chapter 15
so all the way from Genesis to the new
test and here in Leviticus God said his
people were not to eat blood now the
question is if you give blood or if you
receive blood in a transfusion are you
violating this principle I say no um
eating something is different than
taking it
intravenously and if a person yeah if a
person's taking blood and it's usually
they give you the same blood type it's
because a person is going to die unless
they get that these laws are principally
Health laws and um you know God doesn't
want us eating blood because it is true
disease can be transferred from animal
to animal through the blood and uh you
know you've probably heard about
different cultures where they eat blood
sausage and they eat blood and even a
lot of the blood solden or meat sold in
Market still has the blood in it it's
not Kosher in the way it's prepared but
um I I believe that it's a stretch and I
know my friends the Jehovah Witnesses
are thinking that it's a sin if someone
gets a blood transfusion but you know if
a person's going to die if they don't
get a blood
transfusion um and they're getting the
same blood type you're not getting the
blood of animals you're getting the
blood of another human with the same
type I don't see that as a violation of
this command you're not eating
blood these are dietary
issues that's what I thought I I I read
that verse and I just that verse was not
speaking to me that donating blood was
bad it just wasn't doing it for me now I
think that you're going to be blessed
for uh sharing blood uh Jesus by the way
kind of gave the human race a blood
transfusion it's interesting that one of
the last things that happens on the
cross is H they gave Jesus sour wine in
the first miracle of Christ he gives
fresh wine Jesus basically the wine he
said drink this grape juice it's a
symbol of my blood and Christ in pouring
out his blood for the sins of the world
uh is something like given us a
transfusion of new life we receive his
new life into us and and so you know
drinking that grape juice is a symbol of
that so hey I appreciate that by the way
Juan we do have a book that talks a
little bit about some of these dietary
laws it's called God's free health plan
if you'd like a copy of the Bible
secrets to long and Abundant Life call
800 83567 47 we'll send it to you free
God's free Health Plan is the name of
that study with that we're going to go
to Don who's calling from is it Brandon
Florida
don don you're on the air you there hi
hi yes I'd like to know is there any
verses in the Bible that refer to Jesus
as God's son before he was born on the
Earth well let me think here um you do
have Psalm
2:12 where it says kiss the son lest he
be
angry and um some have wondered if this
was a Messianic
prophecy um if you look in Daniel
chapter
7 it talks no no no it's Daniel chapter
3 where Shadrach Meek and Abednego are
in the fiery furnace King Nebuchadnezzar
says didn't I throw three men in the
furnace but I'm looking and now I four
and the form of the fourth is like the
Son of God and so I do think there are a
few scattered references in the Old
Testament that you'll find um that you
know seem to reference Jesus as the son
prior to his coming to Earth or what we
call the
Incarnation I just wantan to know
because I know there's certain uh
Christian groups that believe that Jesus
was a created being because um like
verses John 3:16 where he's referred to
as the begotten of the father yes I've
heard I was just wondering how to
explain
that yeah I I've heard that before and
of course when it says that Jesus is
begotten it means the only time God was
begotten as a human is in Christ God the
son was born or begotten as a human that
happened at the know Incarnation with
Mary but he existed before that because
Christ said before Abraham was I am and
the Bible says all things that were made
and this is in the Gospel of John
chapter 1 all things that were made were
made by him now if everything was made
by Christ and you read that in Hebrews
you read it in Colossians if everything
is made by Christ then he couldn't have
made
himself the Bible doesn't say everything
but Jesus was made by Christ it says all
things that were made and again in
Revelation he's referred to as the Alpha
and Omega from Everlasting to
Everlasting Thou Art God you can read in
Genesis when it says in the beginning
God created the heavens and the Earth
well if Jesus is
Everlasting he must be God you see what
I'm
saying yes yes thank you very much that
clears it up for me I appreciate it and
one of the other strong points just in
concluding that thought d by the way I
we'll send you a book on the Trinity
that talks about the Eternal nature of
Jesus and it's free if you call 8835
6747 ask for the book on the Trinity I
was going to just add that um God is
love and if God has always been love you
can't have love without another person
to express that love so Jesus must have
always existed but a good question I
appreciate that Don don't forget to
request the free book on the Trinity and
it'll give you all those references
there with that we're going to talk next
to Ed who's calling from is it KP white
Michigan Ed you're on the air yes car
white okay get real close to your phone
please oh I got it on speaker yeah that
that always sounds a little further away
but go ahead does want need to okay
pastor um you know I was driving tonight
I was driving home from the store and
this thing popped into my mind and it
was uh
you know before our Earth
before whatever I'm trying to understand
that how come Satan was jealous of Jesus
and war broke out in heaven but only it
broke out in
heaven uh when when this earth existed I
guess and then you know why was Satan
cast to Earth well why was there war in
heaven
but see I'm having a hard time trying to
explain it because it's a hard it's a
hard thing to grasp uh would it broke
out because there's other
worlds you know and and I don't know
that that thought popped into my mind
well let let me take a stab at trying to
answer what I think you're asking um I
in the Bible it tells us that Satan was
originally Lucifer he was a beautiful
angel he was sinless he had no problems
and then as a result of that um he was
he was filled with pride because of his
power and his Beauty and he ultimately
wanted the position and the power that
God possessed and he was jealous until
finally he tempted a third of the Angels
he convinced them to join him in this
Rebellion against God saying God's
government was unfair Satan was expect H
from the paradise of God from Heaven he
eventually found some creatures on this
planet in our first parents Adam and Eve
that listen to him instead of God and he
sort of set up his headquarters down
here to continue his battle against God
and he fights it out in human lives and
so um the reason that war that started
in heaven is really going to be finished
with the war of Armageddon here on Earth
it's a battle between Christ and Satan
it started like it says Michael in the
Dragon in Revelation 12 now Ed we have a
free study guide that talks about this
battle in great detail and it's called
did God create a devil if you call that
phone number that we've been sharing
tonight 800 83567 47 and ask for the
study guide did God create a devil we
will send you a free copy of that it
covers the exact things you're asking in
your question thank you very much
appreciate your call Ed and with that
we're going to be talking next to Dylan
who's calling from Las Vegas Nevada
Dylan you're on the
air Dylan in Las Vegas hi how you
doing um I'm good I uh I had a friend
and he was younger than me and I'm a
boxer and he him and his brother they
showed me a lot in boxing but they were
younger than me and we all later on
became pro
professional and he had committed
suicide
and you know I've read the scriptures
and it about blasphemy of the Holy
Spirit but it doesn't really
specifically say I know like in the
Catholic religion it's the mortal sin
they say uhuh but I I mean I'd like to
feel and seem that you know I know it's
a selfish sin but is that the mystery of
faith that maybe it isn't like you still
could go to heaven if you did that well
I think we need to be careful not to say
that every person who commits suicide is
automatically lost because uh you know
I've been a pastor for over 30 years and
have had to deal with this and some
young people some not so young people I
know have gone through terrible bouts of
depression some of it may have been due
to a chemical imbalance some people were
beside thems with physical suffering
from cancer and um they just you know
they may have lived a a wonderful
Christian Life
and then just in the last you know weeks
of their life because they were
overwhelmed with physical pain they did
something that was totally out of
character so is God going to judge them
on the the Panorama of their life or on
a mistake that was made in the last
hours when they weren't
clear sometimes they're under the effect
of medication for their cancer you know
what I'm saying so I think we've got to
be very careful not to say every suicide
is a automatically eternally lost but at
the same time I run into young people or
they get discouraged they say I'm just
going to kill myself and because I pray
first you know Jesus will take me to
Heaven that's also a mistake because if
the last Act of your life is self-murder
um you know God says don't kill then
that's not good because um we're
supposed to have faith as Christians
we're supposed to have hope and when a
person kills thems it's usually a sign
that they've lost faith and hope you see
what I'm saying and so there's a balance
there
Samson you know the story of Samson in
the Bible Dylan he pushed down this
Temple and it fell on him and um
basically he he killed himself but he
did it to deliver God's people from
their enemies and Jesus even said no man
takes my life I Lay My Life down so
that's a sacrifice which of course is
different from a suicide so I I do I
don't agree with the um the teaching
that says that it is the unpardonable
sin
okay uh you know I I I'm I now that I'm
older now I I don't agree with it either
I did when I was younger but you know
because it was like I went to Catholic
school and I mean that's what we were
taught as younger but and when you read
the scriptures and you get to a
relationship with Christ and you know
him better you know that's what I feel
too in my heart I just wanted to call
and and ask you and get that answer from
you because you have helped me through a
lot of time listening to your show well
bless your heart well thank you Dylan
you know I have a book we'll send you a
free copy and it's called Beyond Mercy
what is the unpardonable sin and it
talks specifically about this you just
call the number
88356 747 and ask for the book book on
the unpardonable sin and we'll send you
that for free and appreciate your
calling tonight with that uh we're going
to talk next to uh Denny who's calling
from Cross Lake Minnesota Minnesota
where where's number eight there it is
Denny are you on the
air I am hey thank you for
waiting well thank you for having me in
your program pastor Pastor Doug yeah my
question is uh in the
Bible if you
are uh saved
committed uh Christian person
that uh has the holy spirit in them I
mean a real true Christian is it
possible
to
have uh
demons all right well that's a good
question um first of all no man can
serve two
masters but that doesn't mean a person
can't experience a battle in their heart
between two
masters there can be a battle in a
person's heart between light in
darkness Peter the Apostle was a
follower of Jesus but Satan was trying
to get Peter and Jesus even said but one
time Jesus turns to Peter and he says
Get Behind Me Satan because Peter was
trying to encourag Jesus not to go to
the Cross he said get behind me Satan
you don't desire the things of God and
then Jesus told Peter Satan has desired
to have you that he might sift you like
wheat but I've prayed for you that your
faith does not fail and when you're
converted strengthen the Brethren uh
Peter went through a real struggle the
night he denied Christ and so a Believer
can feel that battle inside but a person
cannot be Spirit F filled and devil
filled at the same time does that make
sense yes I I believe there's not room
for two yeah so you you know all of us
feel the battle between light and
darkness in our hearts and that doesn't
mean you're not a Christian even Jesus
was tempted right so being tempted is
not a sin Christ was tempted it's when
you surrender to Temptation that it
turns into
sin and um you know I have a book I'll
be happy to send you a free copy that
talks about um 12 tips to resisting
temptation you can just ask for the book
on tips for resisting temptation we'll
send you a free copy Denny and it's 800
6747 to get your free copy that book by
the way that does open up another line
if someone wants to call with a Bible
question it's 800
God says 800
46372 97 and we thank you for your call
Denny going to talk next to John or John
E calling from is it severville
Tennessee Seville yeah yeah thank you
for calling Hey thank
you how can we help tonight oh sorry I
was wanting to know uh I'm driving right
now so I didn't have time to look up the
verse but on a previous uh show I was
was listening to they mentioned uh uh
you know asking uh God for forgiveness
and uh repenting of your sin and then uh
uh confessing your sin and God being
just to forgive you uh of you know as
from a point of view of a Christian
who's already been baptized right has
maybe back or committed a sin in his
everyday life and uh you know that
happens to a lot of people and happens
to me uh quite often and uh you know I
pray to God and I confess my sins to him
and uh sometimes I confess my sins to
you know the people I I have in my
fellowship and my Bible study and stuff
but I was want to know uh do you think
that a a person needs to be have a
system or a support group set up or you
know a pastor something where they can
uh confess all their sins that they
commit or uh is confessing a sin to God
enough and I was just asking for
clarification
well you know there's a verse in James
and you might be thinking of this where
it says in James 5:116 confess your
faults to one another and pray for one
another that you might be healed now
confessing your faults or talking about
sins in a general
sense you shouldn't be confessing your
sin to men because only God can forgive
you and there you know is obviously
private sin if you offend your brother
you ought to confess that specifically
to your brother your sister if you do
something public publicly that is you
know shames the church you might stand
up and testify and say you know I I let
everyone down and and um so a public you
know Scandal might require a public
confession but otherwise sin ought to be
confessed privately to God uh David when
he sinned with bath Sheba he prayed in
Psalm 51 he says against thee and thee
only have I sinned and done this wrong
in your sight and so um I do think it's
important to have a support group and
friends that you can really trust and
you know you might say brother or sister
I'm I'm struggling by the way I think
that men ought to have men they can
confide in and women ought to have women
they can confide in or sometimes
unhealthy relationships develop but uh
you ought to have some friends you can
confide and say look I'm I'm struggling
with something and maybe you can pray
for me but you know I don't think it's
healthy for us to get into the
nitty-gritty usually we can be General
and ask people to pray and God knows
what the problem is and they can pray
for us so does that make sense Johnny I
think so that's about where I was at on
it previously but uh uh appreciate the
uh you helping me out and making sure
that I wasn't missing all right hey
thank you so much for your call and you
drive safe all right thank you so much
for your show I really appreciate your
ministry God
bless all right with that we're going to
talk next to Ralph Ralph is calling from
New York New York hi Ralph you're on the
air with Bible answers
live praise the Lord and your question a
question I want to ask you a question
about marriage there's two born again
Christian people they're saved they want
to get
married um they they're not sure if they
should go to City Hall and get married
and get a marriage license or go or just
go to their pastor at regular Christian
church and have the pastor marry them
which which is acceptable before
god well um of course if you get married
in a church you'll still have a license
that the pastor will sign and the
license will be approved by City Hall so
if you get married in the church you can
get the best of both worlds because you
know marriage is also a covenant between
two people in the sight of God now of
course if you get married in City Hall
your marriage is still legal and binding
but if you have two Believers I would
wonder why wouldn't you want to get
married in the
church right yeah so it you know then
you can invite other friends to
celebrate hopefully it's a happy
occasion and you can invite other people
to come and specifically my question is
does God accept if even if you don't
want to go to City Hall and get a
marriage Li does God accept two people
get married in a Christian church and an
anointed pastor of God does God accept
that without a license oh now that
right now that that's a whole different
question if so you're asking then if if
a PE two people want to just have a
pastor conduct the service but they're
not going to do it with legal license I
wouldn't recommend that and I don't
think that's biblical because the Bible
says obey the laws of the land and
marriage also is a covenant that's not
only respected by the church in the
presence of God but it's registered in
the country where you live because there
are laws regarding the disillusion of
marriage and if there ever children
involved there are laws connected with
the protection of the children in that
Covenant and so I would always recommend
that Christian has a legal marriage as
opposed to an illegal marriage a common
law marriage I've never heard really
good Arguments for doing that though I
used to present some of them but they
still weren't good arguments hey
listening friend we're going to take a
brief break don't go anywhere we'll be
coming back with more Bible questions
don't forget you can check us out on the
Internet by going to amazingfacts.org
and and we'll be back in 2
minutes stay tuned Bible answers live
will return in a
[Music]
moment Life's a curious thing I mean
just when things seem under control Wham
you're hit with something new your
marriage is good Suddenly It's on the
brink of divorce
the job's great and then it's gone and
so's your life
savings you feel healthy then your
doctor gives the bad news what's coming
next you could look to the stars but
they don't have the
answers but this does the prophecy Study
Bible by amazing facts this Bible's
special it's 27 personal study guides
lead you on a life-changing journey
through God's word to discover real
answers to Life's questions from health
and relationships to family and the
future the hopes in here get your
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible today
by calling
85387 275 or visit AF bookstore.com
Can't Get Enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at afv.com .g at aftv.org
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day 7 days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aftv.org
[Music]
every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers
live this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now let's join Pastor Doug Bachelor
for more Bible anwers
[Music]
live Hello friends this is Pastor Doug
Bachelor and we're going to go back to
the phones in a minute if you do have a
Bible question then give us a call 800
7297 and uh you probably heard us
mention during the announcements and uh
over the break we're having a special
program that begins this Friday evening
it'll broadcast live on aftv that's
amazing facta TV you can even find that
just by going to amazingfacts.org it is
called Mighty Men of God and if you're
in the greater Sacramento area you're
welcome to join us in person or watch
anywhere in the world online that's
going to begin at 700 p.m. Friday
evening we'll also have programs on
Saturday morning and Saturday afternoon
Mighty Men of God it's especially for
men tell your friends you can go to the
website and find out more about that all
right with that rambling announcement
now I'm going to go to our next phone
call talk to Bobby who's been waiting
patiently calling from Sacramento
California Bobby you're on the air well
thank you for having me my question is I
have a girlfriend that always tells me
you can't eat pork and I want to know
why we can't eat pork we can eat
everything else but we can't eat pork
you're talking about well course you can
you can eat whatever you want you can
eat whatever you want to eat
if you don't care you know but if if you
care I mean your person could eat
Twinkies all day if they want So when
you say can't eat pork you're talking
about when the Bible talks about what's
forbidden is that what you're asking
yeah yeah it's pretty clear from cover
to cover in the Bible that pigs are
considered unclean they were scavengers
they still are today you know the
original plan let's just take this
sequentially now Bobby you know in the
Garden of Eating the original plan was
that man doesn't eat animals right I
mean in heaven we're not going to be
chasing around chickens and cutting off
their heads and in heaven we'll be
eating from the Tree of Life and they'll
be fruit and Vineyards and we're not
going to be eating animals and it was
only after sin man began to eat animals
and then God said if you're going to eat
animals you're not required to but if
you're going to eat them don't eat the
unclean animals and certain animals were
specified as unclean because they're
scavengers you're not supposed to eat
dogs you're not supposed to eat skunks
or cockroaches or pigs and and Jews
Muslims and most many I should say
Christians around the world know that
because they read it in the Bible a lot
of Christians say well but those were
all dietary laws and if you cook it real
good doesn't matter but the problem with
pork isn't just killing the trar the lar
of a pork is actually the densest meat
in sodium and fat and U when you think
about what pigs eat they are literally
scavengers it's not a good meat even if
you hear commercials that say oh it's
the other white meat and they trying to
make it sound elegant and light I hear
that all the time yeah it's pork is is
really I used to feed pigs and I'll tell
you they are
disgusting I have another question for
you yeah when Jesus turned the water
into wine I guess it must have been a
thousand people there I don't know
doesn't say but yeah there's a lot of
wine he made so there probably with
hundreds anyway so why can't we uh can
we drink wine and and and have a good
time and whatever well the wine that
Jesus made made in the Bible you don't
find the word grape juice anywhere in
the Bible what they did is they used one
word for the juice of the grape they
didn't have wine as we we call Wine Wine
now and we call grape juice grape juice
in Bible times there was only one word
for both for instance it says in Isaiah
65 as the new wine is in the cluster
well if it's new wine it's unfermented
it means it's just been squeezed out of
the grape right and even Jesus said you
don't put new wine in old wine skins or
it'll ferment then the wine skins burst
and so um the wine that Jesus made at
that wedding Feast many believe was
unfermented he they said you've saved
the best for last because you could get
the bad wine all year long but you could
get fermented wine all year long but you
could only get fresh wine during the
Harvest Time and so true I've got a book
I'll be happy to send you a free copy
that is called it's called the alcohol
in Christian yeah I'd like to have that
yeah we'll send you all you got to do is
call we'll send you a copy it's got all
the verses in the Bible that talk about
the AL alcohol and how should a
Christian relate to that I'm of the
opinion go ahead I'm sorry I think my
girlfriend uh she told me that wine was
called grape juice or something like
that yeah not always but many time you
know when when King David tried to get
Uriah drunk it was real wine and when
Noah got drunk and he ran around naked
it was the alcoholic kind and when lot
got drunk and he slept with his
daughters it was obviously the alcoholic
kind or the alcohol kind I should say
but um a number of times in the Bible it
uses the word wine and it's just talking
about grape juice so I think I don't
think Jesus made a bunch of I don't
think Jesus made a bunch of booze for a
party in John Chapter 2 so you know when
you think of all the misery I you know I
think that there was a a baseball player
that just died yesterday prominent
baseball player they were riding their
boat um at night and it's in it's
suspected that there is alcohol involved
so many people die from alcohol rated
injuries and disease and crime that um
Christians shouldn't support that it is
a people do get addicted we know about
Alcoholics so it is an addictive drug
and why Christians would support that
people don't get addicted to grape juice
they get addicted to the alcohol in the
beer or the wine or the whiskey whatever
it is and so it's a very addictive drug
and um I don't recommend any Christian
drink any alcohol I yeah I uh had any
for years I quit drinking alcohol in
1985 when I was a born again Christian
you know yeah well that's about like me
I've ever ever done well you're better
off let me send you that book that I was
talking about and it's called wine in
the Christian all you got to do is call
the number 8835
6747 and uh we'll send you a free copy
thank you very much Bobby with that
we're GNA go next and talk to
Dominique who's calling from Temple
Texas Dominique you're on the air with
Bible answers live okay how you doing
I'm glad to be on air with you glad
you're calling all right uh I had two
quick questions uh my first question
comes out of Romans 9 uh vers 13 as it
is written Jacob I have loved but Esau I
have hated and uh my other question is
is about Moses when he grew up in the
pharaoh's house because there is some
teaching out there that's saying that
that Moses was a a black man because of
the Egyptians culture and if you look
back at all of the pictures and
paintings and so on and so forth it'll
let you know that they were uh black
black people in that nation and that
Moses had to be black because there's no
way that he could be able to stay in
Pharaoh's house and not be uh noticed
you know to the point to where him for
him to stand out but he in it my
question is is you got two questions
your first one you want me to answer
about Jacob from Romans right yes sir
Romans 9 and the other one about Moses
yes sir all right many people have
thought in that verse there in Romans
where he says Jacob I've Loved an Esau I
hated it means that I just liked Jacob
because of who he was and I disliked
Esau because of who he was uh actually
Paul is quoting Malachi 1:2 where he
says I have loved you but the Lord says
you say how do you love us is not Esau
Jacob's brother to close the Lord yet
you've loved Jacob and here what he's
saying is that he loved the people of
Israel and he was angry at the people of
Edom the children of Esau because of
their sin it wasn't that God arbitrarily
was saying I like uh Israelites more
than I like the
it was basically just saying
that because of Jacob's faithfulness and
because of Esau's being carnal their
descendant
were more faithful among Jacob and they
were more carnal among the and
that's just God saying that he loves
certain characteristics I mean God loves
everybody we know that and your next
question was about Moses well the
Bible's pretty clear that Moses was from
the tribe of Levi his father was amram
his mother was jocked and they were all
from the tribe of Levi and Levi was one
of the sons of Jacob so they were from
uh Hebrew descent that was not from
Jewish descent because the Jews are the
descendants of the tribe of Judah now
does that make sense Dominique oh okay
now that because that's starting to
clear up the picture a lot because uh
what's being taught a lot out there now
is they connect the two they say Hebrew
Israelites you know and they called they
they say they're Jewish you know so that
that kind of made sense that he was a he
said he was a Hebrew but he was not
Jewish that's right the the Hebrews
Abraham the word Hebrew comes from an
ancient word that means cross over
Hebrew uh the Hebrews crossed over the
Euphrates and went to Canaan they called
them the people that crossed over and uh
for instance Ishmael the Arabs they're
Hebrews but they're not Jews the Jews
were the descendants of the tribe of
Judah that came back from the Babylonian
captivity most of the other 10 tribes
were scattered among the Assyrians and
they intermarried and sort of
disappeared but um so anyway I don't
know if that helps you a little bit with
that question but uh yeah the Bible says
God is made of one blood all people we
are all brothers and sisters now in
Christ and we appreciate your question
Dominique with that we're going to talk
next to Allan who has been waiting
patiently Allan from Atlanta Georgia you
are on the air with Bible answers live
good evening Pastor um I'm really
interested in in hearing uh your
thoughts on this because I was listening
to a radio program some months back and
and the pastor
uh got into this really long- winded
explanation about this and try as I
might I just I just couldn't follow his
line of reasoning but um there's an Old
Testament prophecy you know I'm I'm sure
you're aware of um in Isaiah says behold
the Virgin shall shall conceive and bear
a son and shall call his name Emanuel
but of course in the New Testament we
know our savior is Jesus so what is how
do you reconcile the Old Testament and
New Testament prophecies in that regard
as far as Old Testament saying Emanuel
but of course you know in the New
Testament the Savior being born and
named is Jesus yeah well when you think
about it Jesus actually has many names
um the word Emmanuel the names of Christ
all mean something the word Emanuel
means God With Us whenever you hear the
word l in Hebrew it means Elohim God
like
Rachel Daniel Daniel means my judge is
God uh Elijah Elisha
um and Jesus his real name in Hebrew is
yua or Joshua Jesus is kind of the Greek
pronunciation of that which means god
Jehovah is Savior and so these are
actually titles of Christ but you get
into Revelation and Jesus says you know
I am I am that I am and he he says I'm
the alpha and omega I am the Morning
Star I am the lamb I'm the door I'm the
Water of Life so Christ has so many
titles and one of the prominent titles
is God would be with us God became a man
to dwell among us to save us and that's
why one of his names is Emmanuel so
you're right it isn't the name that Mary
gave him or that was given by the angel
but it is one of the titles of Christ
that was uh foretold and when you get to
the New Testament Matthew repeats this
verse is that right yeah Matthew
actually quotes from Isaiah 14 and said
as the prophet has said a virgin would
conceive and bring forth a
on okay great okay well thank you I
really appreciate that thank you Alan
hope that made more sense than the last
answer you got all right with that we're
going to be that frees up a line if you
do have a Bible question 800 God says
800 463
7297 talking next to Stephen in Savannah
Georgia Stephen you're on the air with
Bible answers
live yes thank you glad to be here thank
you uh P yeah I had a question about the
new jerus last four square yeah uh you
know I figured and uh in in Miles 1500
Miles Square which would be 375 time
four right and I was just I was just
musing it seems to me that it would have
to be like a cube or a pyramid what what
what say you well that's a good question
because I when I teach seminars and talk
about the New Jerusalem and I've looked
for good artist Concepts uh some of the
artists draw it as a cube because it
does say the Bas is
square and it tells us you know the the
walls are 144 cubits some have wondered
does that mean the walls are 144 cubits
wide or 144 cubits High it doesn't say
in the original text um and so some have
the walls going around 144 cubits High
which is 218 ft and then they have from
there the city sloping up to a pinnacle
like a
pyramid and um others I've actually seen
them draw it where it says the link and
the breadth the Hebrew does say the
length breadth and height of the city
are the same so whenever you got
something where the length bread and
height are the same it becomes a cube
and so it is a mystery
um it's big we know that whether it's
going to be more Cube shaped or pyramid
shaped it's hard to
say um you know the Babylonian Kings
they they in Babylon they built these
pyramids that were more like zigarts you
you know they they had the um the step
pyramids or they had paths going around
them so I don't think that God's basing
his archae or his architecture off the
Babylonian Kings
but anyway so yeah the Bas of square is
about all we know and it's big it's
ginormous yeah which means there's room
for us right if you take a pyramid and
you go to the top and just push it
straight down it becomes a square that's
right you see yeah and and a lot of the
a lot of the uh esoteric and occult type
symbolism is Pyramid of course that
doesn't surprise me because uh Satan has
uh you know counterfeited the rainbow
for other things you know yeah that's
right they take Divine symbols and they
put some kind of cultish designs on it
hey I appreciate your call Stephen and
you you know we have a lesson that talks
about the city of God that actually has
some of these artist Concepts in it very
much like what you're talking about so
if you want to see our lesson with
illustration of the city of God then we
want you to send for our lesson talking
about City in space this heavenly Space
City and we'll send it to you that
number 800
83567 47 will send you our lesson on the
New Jerusalem the city in space we say
that because it comes down out of Heaven
all right who is next Ana is that right
line eight Ana calling from Toronto
Canada are you there
Anya hi Doug hi thank you for for
calling thanks for your
patience I love you oh well it just be
aware my wife's listening in but thank
you very much don't worry not in that
way but I love listening to your
servants I'm so excited to be talking to
you well glad to meet you too I just got
baptized two years ago which will be in
October coming up praise the
Lord and like I said to the lady my
problem is um anger
you so you struggle you wondering what
the Bible says about how to deal with
anger
yes
well the Bible tells us Christ with the
Holy Spirit is offering us a peace that
passes understanding typically when we
get angry it's because our pride has
been
offended and and when we have the mind
of Christ and the spirit of Christ and
when we are crucified with Christ you
know it's hard to hurt a dead
person when we're offended it's because
the old nature is alive and are we
become personally offended and our
selfishness and our pride is offended
and so the more we humble ourselves and
ask for the mind and the spirit of
Jesus the easier it is to have peace so
that we're not offended okay and you
know um uh we do have some lessons that
talk about you know what I've actually
got a sermon where I talk about anger
you can watch for free online if you you
go to even YouTube and you just type in
Doug Bachelor um I think it's called the
age of
Rage uh if you just age yeah the age of
rage is um is uh you can I know I did a
sermon on that I know the text is online
but I I have a lot of scriptures and
principles and even some funny
illustrations in there that I think
you'll
enjoy and uh yeah just you can Google
that Doug Bachelor age of Rage I found
out sometimes when I want to find own
references I just Google it now it's
almost it's almost quicker than anything
else okay but hey don't forget you can
still find it on the Amazing Facts
website as
well and one more thing Doug do you have
any books on with the Sabbath because I
have a problem like telling anytime I
tell my friends or anyone like the the
SE the S day is on a Saturday they
struggle to battle with me try to tell
me where does it say it in the Bible and
yes I we've got some great material for
you two things Anya one is we have a
study guide that's talked talks about
the uh lost day of History we'll send
you that and we have a brand new
magazine that is really uh incredible
dealing with a subject called the the um
uh the rest of your life and it's about
the Sabbath the rest of your life and so
if you call our Resource number 88 35
6747 we'll be sending you those and you
can then share one if you like them you
can buy more but we'll send you the
first two for free and uh ask for those
studies nice to meet you Ana and we'll
talk next with um Paul who is calling
from uh Royal Oak Michigan Paul you're
on the air with Bible answers live
Pastor Doug thank you so much um I want
to first of all just real quick say that
I am ABS I've never heard you your show
before I've never and I understand
you're filling in for somebody but I
just want to say that you're you are
really making me feel good about what is
often times gray murky you know hard to
internalize and understand stuff you you
have a fascinating awareness of this and
it's great well thank you actually I'm
not filling in my co-host is missing and
we're here every week so we hope you
keep us keep us on your dial Paul and
keep coming back yeah um so what I
originally wanted to ask I want to ask
in one second but to follow up if I can
just to understand better because the
girl asked about anger yeah um if if
someone does something more or less to
to steal from you you said pride is
usually the root of anger if somebody
was to steal something from you and I'm
just hypothesizing is that is that
somehow rooted differently no and I'm
glad you asked that because I I I didn't
mean to leave people with the impression
that all anger is because of selfishness
God can get angry and he's certainly not
selfish um the Bible speaks about even
Jesus getting angry and chasing the
money changers out of the temple so
there is a righteous indignation Paul
got angry when a sorcerer was trying to
disrupt Paul's evangelism and the guy
was stricken with blindness so there's a
righteous kind of indignation where
you're thinking about others you know if
you saw you know an old woman being
mugged you'd be angry and that would be
a righteous form of indignation or a
child being abused you'd be angry and
that it's appropriate I'm talking about
you know so often When we struggle with
anger typically it's because we somehow
have been uh
offended um but that doesn't mean yeah
if you're someone steals from you I know
someone stole my car and I was
angry right and and and even to the
point of taking action POS I know you
said the Bible says this isn't even what
I was supposed to ask and I apologize to
the gentleman who let me talk to you
because he greens the calls but you know
even to the point of taking physical
action like I was just talking to
somebody earlier tonight about like if
you're attacked by somebody or whatever
the Bible doesn't imply that you're not
supposed to fight back physically right
because I know Jesus said One Cheek
smack you know offer the other but
that's not what that's about right no I
I think Christ is just illustrating that
uh you know rather than retaliating we
should offer the other cheek and
forgiveness is usually better but
obviously if some you know if some
stranger on the street were to come and
uh assault me I'd do all I could to
defend myself I mean that's the natural
self-preservation I think God's built
into everybody okay but what's the real
question before we run out of time yeah
yeah yeah so and this was this is the
question and it was spun off of another
question from another it's about
Temptation uhuh it's about when
Temptation becomes sin
because I you you know I never really
thought about it Jesus was tempted but
he didn't s
so all right let me let say you look at
someone and you lost right that's let me
jump in here real quick because we are
going to the clocks against us here if a
man for instance looks and notices
there's a woman that is attractive or
she's dressed in a provocative way he
can be aware of that that doesn't mean
it's a sin to notice that because you
see things they register it's when you
then begin to dwell upon it and embrace
it then it can start becoming a
distraction in a sense
and so obviously you need to recognize a
sin in order to resist it it's when you
embrace it and want it then it becomes
forbidden hey thank you for your call
Paul I hope you give us another chance
and we hear from you again next week
friends we got another amazing fact
coming in just a moment stand by after
these
[Music]
announcements thank you for listening to
today's broadcast we hope you understand
your Bible even better than before
before Bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts a faith-based Ministry
located in Sacramento
[Music]
California did you know that Noah was
present at the birth of Abraham okay
maybe he wasn't in the room but he was
alive and probably telling stories about
his floating Zoo from the creation of
the world to the last day events of
Revelation bible.com is a free resource
where you can explore major Bible events
and characters enhance your knowledge of
the Bible and draw closer to God's word
go deeper visit the amazing Bible
timeline at
bible.com if you'd like to enhance your
study of God's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF book
bookstore.com which offers thousands of
inspiring books DVDs and more to help
you get the most out of God's word to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at 800
6747 or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]
have you ever heard a mouse howl like a
wolf well what would you expect would
happen when a creature changes its
Destiny from the hapless prey to Mighty
Predator from the outside they look very
much like just an oversized field mouse
cute brown fur white on the underbelly
nice little beady eyes but that's where
the similarities stop grasshopper mice
are very unusual making them the objects
of great interest for animal
researchers these furry little creatures
are found in the harsh deserts of North
America they're very territorial in
nature and they will monopolize and fend
off 25 acres they don't build their own
homes but sort of confiscate the Burrows
and the homes of other
creatures they're not called grasshopper
mice cuz they hop around but it's
because they eat a lot of grasshoppers
in fact scientists have discovered
grasshopper mice are the only mice that
are purely
carnivorous they hunt much like cats or
weasels stalking their prey in a
predatory fashion and when they pounce
they are ferocious sometimes even taking
on snakes and scorpions and
centipedes when a grasshopper mouse gets
into a fierce battle with a snake or a
scorpion or centipede they may be bit or
stung several times but what is amazing
to researchers is they've noticed when
they are bitten they somehow shake it
off because they convert the Toxin and
the Venom to
painkiller I think you can understand
why this information would be of special
interest to scientists that are trying
to discover new ways for people to deal
with chronic
pain what of the most intriguing
characteristics of these little
creatures is when they're defending
their territory or celebrating a vict
ictory over some adversary they'll throw
back their head and let out this Earth
shaking howl that's a mousy howl check
it
[Music]
out the grasshopper mouse is not the
only member of creation that can survive
encounters with venomous predators in
Luke 10:19 it says behold I will give
you authority to trample on serpents and
scorpions and over all the power of the
enemy nothing will by any means hurt you
we don't have to be the biggest and the
strongest to defeat our enemy and let
out that Victory Roar when God called
David to be king no human would have
guessed that he had it in him he was
young and insignificant from the outside
he looked like there was no greatness in
him but when God looked at his heart he
saw courage humility compassion and love
David wasn't perfect and he made
mistakes but through God's power he was
able to conquer
Giants friend God does not intend that
you live out the rest of your life
cowering and trembling like a little
field mouse if God can take the
grasshopper mouse and give him courage
so that he fights snakes and scorpions
and centipedes if God can put in the
heart of David the courage to fight
giants like Goliath then he can give you
that same Courage the scriptures say God
has not given you the spirit of fear but
of power love and a sound mind and you
can have that peace in your heart when
you invite the Prince of Peace in your
heart why don't you do that right
now for over 50 years amazing facts has
shared the wonderful news of Salvation
and provided millions of Bible resources
to people all over the world we built
churches in India proclaimed God's word
in China and have sent free Bible
studies around the globe today's program
and free resources were made possible by
our Ministry Partners caring individuals
like you if you've been blessed by
amazing facts would you please consider
partnering with us to reach others with
the Bible truth your financial support
today will help keep programs like this
on the air so the blessings you've
received can be shared with others to
find out more about becoming a Ministry
partner please visit our website at
amazingfacts.org
[Music]